Los Angeles la cité des anges ou plutôt
celle des sales petits secrets
les gens me paient pour enquêter sur les
activités de ces citoyens les plus
huppés je suis détective privé
mon nom est Philippe Malo
vos enquêtes à quel point sont-elles
privées monsieur Marleau que puis-je
faire pour vous j'aimerais que vous
retrouviez mon amant il a disparu sans
dire au revoir avait-il des choses à
cacher
qui n'en a pas
[Musique]
que cherchent vraiment ma fille ma mère
était dans le cinéma
elle doit penser qu'il y a quelque chose
entre nous
j'ai entendu dire que vous cherchiez
quelqu'un ne cherche-t-on pas tous
quelqu'un je vous paierai 1000 dollars
si vous le retrouvez pour moi un puzzle
à de nombreuses pièces je ne sais pas
exactement ce que vous allez trouver
je vais nettoyer ce trois rat et vous
faire tomber avec moi j'apprécie votre
façon de ne pas avoir peur
quand vous le devriez
ils sont tous impliqués dans ce complot
vous continuerez à chercher parce que
que la police vous douchera pas mais moi
je n'hésiterai pas
tous les gens qu'il vaut mieux éviter
d'emmerder dans cette ville ceux-là sont
en haut de la liste les secrets à
Hollywood c'est de savoir quand votre
temps est révolué
je peux pas m'empêcher de me demander
qui a gagné monsieur Marlo je ferai tout
ce qui est à mon pouvoir pour vous
mettre en prison
[Musique]
nous avons tous nos petits secrets
monsieur Marlon
et les vôtres de secret
vous devrez aussi les garder pour vous
[Musique]